I actually got to go to the Hall of Fame
induction ceremony for my dad
[Music]
obviously I'm proud I'm proud all the
time but getting to be there
was definitely experience I'll never
forget Eminem became a member of the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame earlier this
month I had to um
really fight my way through man to try
to break through in this music and I'm
so honored and I'm so grateful that I'm
even able to be up here doing hip-hop
music and made a rare public appearance
to accept the honor with his daughter
Haley Jade by his side almost died from
an overdose in 2007.
which kind of sucked because Haley plug
your ears
because drugs were delicious
and I thought we had a good thing going
man but I'm like I had to go and [ __ ] it
all up and take too many now Haley is
dishing out the Deets of that special
day including the moment that left her
shook but the camera I swear like was
this close to my face and it was like a
lower angle you know because the guy was
kneeling and all I could think was like
do I have a booger the Michigan native
opens up about the trip to LA with her
dad on her podcast just a little shady
at the actual ceremony
they while while my dad was giving the
speech they wanted to like film the
audience reaction and they want to like
film my reaction God damn
okay Haley you're good
I feel like people just assume that like
I've been in a situation like that
before but truly I that's never I've
never had that happen yeah she admits
that while her dad is super famous for
her it's a culture shock to have cameras
in her face
I just like start panicking in my head
am I trying to just focus on the speech
folks like pay attention and but the
camera I swear like was this close to my
face all I could think was like do I
have a Booker and my head I'm like don't
make any sudden movements and but of
course like like it like and it was like
to the point where I was like barely
blinking I think of course this isn't
the first time Haley showed up to
support her dad back in February she
proved she's the rapper's biggest fan at
Super Bowl 56 where M performed during
the halftime show the Grammy winner
brought the house down with a special
rendition of his oscar-winning song lose
yourself and Haley was right there in
the stands posting clips of her dad's
performance on her insta story
[Music]
is everything
[Music]
of course fans of the rapper know that
Haley has been a huge inspiration behind
many of his songs like Haley's Song and
Mockingbird Taylor
is whether she's with me or not she's
with me every day she has been
my main like source of drive and
motivation when I'm gone also name
checks her daddy
wait Haley baby your daddy's busy and
back in 2020 Eminem explained that it
was a priority to make sure Haley and
her siblings were unaffected by the fame
money and privilege it's definitely
important to to keep your kids grounded
you got to be right inside
otherwise none of it means nothing and
it appears
really explained that while it was nice
poured her dad
actually really good to have went and
it's something I'll never forget but
when stuff like that happens it it feels
just not like real life
yeah and it just feels like fake I love
being at home like I I love being home I
love my life as soon as I come home it's
just like back to reality like dogs
threw up like you know it's just normal
foreign
[Music]